oh hi i'm chris kohler four-game life
here with Chris Baker as always we just
finished up watching nintendo's e3 2009
press conference which chris baker was a
lot better for hardcore gamers yeah i
think last year the complaint was the
focus was entirely on wii fit wii music
animal crossing games that long time
nintendo fans didn't really care about
this year it was just you know throwing
hunks of meat to sharks it was just you
know new game after new game a lot of
them just right down the middle
appealing to longtime nintendo fans yep
there are the rumor was that there was
going to be a new mario game for the wii
and that was the first thing they talked
about new super mario brothers wii
apparently Shigeru Miyamoto creator of
mario has been thinking for about 15
years how can i make a four player
traditional mario style game and it
looks like they've done it you're going
to play four players simultaneously in a
traditional mario game fighting for
power ups it actually looks like a lot
of fun but that wasn't the only mario
game then out super mario galaxy 2 is
also coming to wii new super mario
brothers weed this year mario galaxy 2
sometime in the far future yeah there
was also an announcement of a new
Metroid game this one made with Team
Ninja and it looked like a radical
departure for the series not doing the
first person point of view that the last
few Metroid Prime did yeah no it's
definitely not a Metroid Prime game but
it is metroid called metroid other m for
the we made by team ninja creators of
ninja gaiden and it's going to really
explore the backstory of samus around a
lot of cutscenes that previous Metroid
games didn't have again not coming this
year coming 2010 but something that
hardcore gamers can really look forward
to Nintendo of course also owns the
casual space and so they talked up a
brand new Wii Fit that's going to let
you put together your own exercise
routines you know no more no more
selecting through menus and taking 45
minutes to do a 20-minute workout you
can omit all the current interludes
between exercises so that your routine
can move continuously 20 30 even 40
minutes at a time you can go into the
virtual locker room you can put all your
exercises together that looks pretty
interesting that's also coming this year
a lot of games for nintendo DS as well
Mario and Luigi a new RPG starring those
guys is going to be out this fall the
latest Mario and Luigi RPG game
subtitled bowser's inside story has the
world's most famous game brothers
reduced to microbe size and ingested by
their arch enemy where they go to work
checking out Bowser's internal pipe yeah
we also got a closer look at wii sports
resort which will take advantage of the
new wii motionplus controller that gives
you much finer control with a game turn
and twist and it's going to have a lot
more modes than the original wii sports
did which only had three the this time
they were showing archery which looked
really fun sort of a shooting hoops game
there was a skydiving minigame so this
is probably gonna be one of the big
releases for the late summer for
Nintendo I think this was definitely a
return to form you know this is the
Nintendo that we want to see at e3 these
are the sort of game announcements we
want to hear about you know really
excited about Metroid really excited
about two new mario games for the wii
what's what's got you going yeah this
was definitely they were not reinventing
the wheel this year they were you know
showing games using existed and
previously announced controllers I think
that we sports resort looks like a lot
of fun very excited to see more of this
metroid game yeah and i really can't
wait to play new super mario brothers
for wii which we can on the show floor
and we will right now
you